bismillah Allah assalamu alaikum
greetings Appice welcome to the d show
every friday we got a new exciting
episode this week is no exception
subscribe if you haven't already my next
guest has a very inspiring motivating
story and that's what these stories are
meant to do to inspire you to motivate
you to really reflect and to think
what's the purpose of life why am I here
he went through a whole journey now he's
here Honda Deen show to share his
wonderful star give you some highlights
came from a Catholic background then he
just got irritated with religion most
people you know when you're just wanting
to do your own thing you want to be on
at the clubs on the weekends you want to
just be party and you want to be playing
and maybe it's not even all that you
just you don't want no restriction you
feel like religion is just holding me
back so then you just end up denying God
altogether and that's the second phase
of his story he became a an atheist and
then something else happened he wasn't
able he was able to get rid of Santa
Claus and the fairy tale all these fairy
tales from his mind but he realized this
wasn't a fairy tale the belief in the
creator is something inherent and I kept
knocking knocking knocking on his door
and he ended up coming back and I don't
want to give too much away but it's a
very unique and wonderful story we'll be
right back with it here on the D show
enjoy this
this is the welcome back to the DS show
and we have our brother Ali Andalusia
how are you my brother until a good
hamdullah now you we were just before we
started you were actually talking to me
about we met up once in Chicago so you
were you were raised in into the United
States where you are you actually what
city are you from in Chicago are in in
the states in the States wife has women
in Florida Florida yeah it was a because
my parents had migrated but the Ricoh to
New York and then to Florida I was born
there and that we kind of moved around
after that and I was raised in the south
and a lot also in Chicago as well now
before all that happened now you I mean
before you actually took this trip
you're we're not going to reveal where
you're at right now you're actually
studying you you've you took a different
different different direction in life
you figure out the purpose of life you
know tell us a little bit about your
beginnings you're born in the US we
cover that Catholic family but Catholic
upbringing but really no interest in
religion and you hear a lot of that can
you explain that yeah and you know when
my family migrated to the US and
personally Catholics Catholics
generation they didn't really take them
and seriously is you know theologically
in a serious manner it was mostly just
about cultural identity so it was in
that sort of context that I was raised
you know going to church on Sunday was
more of a a
mint of one's attachment to culture to
the Spanish culture - to being Spanish
it wasn't I mean they didn't teach us
really about Jesus or anything like that
to any great extent and so it was like
it's mostly a social hobby and not
respect or cultural identifiers so I was
never really attached to it I believed
in God but it wasn't something that was
as a motivator of my life or
goals in life or a path in life so you
know when I became a teenager I was very
rebellious and uh I decided to go
against that sort of that sort of
cultural identification that that thing
that I saw is merely a hobby and I I've
been through sort of a phase of atheism
I don't really consider it a serious
phase of it because it was more like you
know teenage angst now you also
mentioned that you were kind of you grew
up irritated you know what this
irritation towards religion can you talk
a little bit about that
and I thought that not just sort of a
lot medic to the intestine is more than
speaking in Russian speaking but also in
terms of just how I did my daily life
you know living in a secular society you
know religion to have religion control
you is something it seems that I people
from the imprisonment you know something
that restricts your freedoms it's
nothing it's not seen in a positive
light so I did find it irritating in
that respect I think like many people
who live in a secular world finding
limiting irritating for controlling the
way that they they do things
yeah so yeah I mean I would say that was
my irritation and then you you you what
you had your atheism phase you know we
see that a lot people end up believing
the religion that they're born in and
they did they end up just would you say
you have this kind of this kind of guilt
you're the creator's putting us all of
this this conscious that's that's kind
of you know this moral compass but now
you want to get rid of that too so you
just kind of just deny God altogether so
you can just kind of do whatever you
want so you don't have to worry about
this yeah I mean I think that that is
one of the main psychological reasons
that a lot of youth move away from God
because in a way it's sort of seen as
the last obstacle towards their their
self identification their their freedom
their ability to find themselves you
know in in the world that they are
confused about so this scene is the
ultimate form of freedom so this is sort
of Nietzsche's viewpoint as well when he
mentioned the death of God he wasn't
saying literally in a literal sense he
was he was saying that in a in a way of
liberating humanity so in a way he was
sort of tapping into that natural
instinct of the youth to want to see
ultimate freedom so God has sort of seen
as their last parent you know that they
have to kind of rebel against and
getting rid of him getting rid of God
helps them to to make sense of of that
that desire that ultimate freedom and in
a way you know I just sort of went down
the same path but I would say in many
ways and not looking back now that it
was very superficial it was mainly based
on emotions and sort of just you know
the trend of a secular society so I was
living in yeah we see that today that
tens of thousands of people in the u.s.
commit suicide
yearly it's the second according to the
CDC is the second leading cause of death
suicide for ages between 10 and 24 and
you were no exception to that you tried
all these things now you're going down a
path of ACE atheism and used
getting really depressed at you almost
you were contemplating suicide yes and
there are a lot of other life events
that occurred during that time as well
as you become the arbiter of your own
morality you make a lot of bad mistakes
you when you when you consider yourself
God in a way then you because of your
lack of knowledge and understanding
about the world you make a lot of
foolish mistakes and it led me down a
path of meaninglessness and purpose
purposelessness
and contemplating suicide was not
uncommon even I think among many many of
my peers around me I mean it's very
common thing especially with the youth
as you mentioned so yeah that ISM sort
of didn't help in that respect I think
it really did not help that I didn't
have this grounding and it helped to
rationalize those feelings further and
eventually I did actually attempt to
take my own life
although unsuccessfully hamdulillah
one of the good failures of my life I
would say so a lot to preserve me from
that fate but it was after that that I
kind of woke up because when you try to
take your own life and you're almost
successful your world sort of flips
upside down I mean people I'm sure many
people can identify with with already
what you're going through you have a lot
of traumas that people are going through
in life from many of the challenges and
people are looking for different answers
and you you ended up leaving religion
going towards atheism again things are
not getting better but you actually come
end up coming back to religion now what
happens here well I think that this sort
of traumatic episode helped me to
look at the world that I was living in
look at my own life see a lot of people
they I just want to mention this quickly
before I go on a lot of people have this
notion that traumatic experiences tend
to lead people superficially to accept
religion again yeah I would disagree
with that
what a traumatic experience does easy it
puts your brain and reset mode so it's
like when computer is overloaded you
have to restart and everything gets a
fresh you know fresh beginning and you
get to see everything for what it really
is
like it's a nice example yeah well
that's what that's really what it's what
it's actually about so I don't like it
how you know today in mainstream culture
they sort of make fun of people or look
down on people who have had these
experiences and all you learn on the
religious because of emotions but that's
that's not the case that experience that
I had you know almost taking my own life
and going through this horrible phase
allowed me to finally realize or to look
around you know this the context in
which I was living and to actually
question what was going on see I was so
obsessed with the present moment the
what was going on these little emotions
that I could have him get finally up I
was only seeing that within a small
bubble but in the bubble pops and then
all of a sudden I could actually breathe
I could actually think and so yes I said
lead me back to seeking a higher purpose
seeking a higher higher you know a
better way of life and I mentioned
actually went back to Christianity a
more sincere passion and we're getting
to the religious aspects I would say
that also this whole notion of belief in
God even though I was I consider myself
an atheist it didn't really ever go away
it was always sort of there yeah you
know has sort of a natural tendency that
I could never shake it you know I I
would try I would try to rationalize it
away or try to argue away I'll try to
tell myself it's not there but unlike
you know something like Santa Claus you
know I couldn't do that a head couldn't
it was easy to get rid of Santa Claus
you know that didn't make any sense but
God was always there
even when I didn't want him to be so it
was actually easy to make that
transition back to religion because I
never really did not really lose the
feeling you're always just fighting and
yeah I like I like that you're always
you don't lose that feeling you're
always fighting against it we're gonna
be right back with more of this
wonderful interview here with Allie
don't go anywhere right back you want to
be here every Friday and then we'll try
to give you some short reminders in
between but you can't get that if you're
not coming back to the show every week
Fridays will be releasing it God willing
inshallah subscribe right now and enjoy
all of the content that we're gonna be
putting out for you thank you peace be
with you
Salaam alaikum so I'll make home back
here on the D show with our brother
let's give it away you're all the way in
Malaysia right I'm in Malaysia I'm on
the other side of the world oh so we're
gonna get to why you're in Malaysia and
a few now there was a study Oxford
University I believe they did a study
with 57 researchers 57 20 different
studies I believe and they had concluded
that belief like you were just saying
belief in the Almighty in the Creator
something that's that's naturally built
into all of us and to disbelieve it's
something that you it's acquired you
have to fight hard to accomplish and and
this is a testimony to that even though
you went you had your phase of atheism
you came back to religion you got rid of
Santa Claus because it has but do you
see a lot of people how do you how do
you argue when people they try to put
the Creator God Almighty Allah into this
category of Santa Claus Tooth Fairy and
and now just the same way you you're
you're brought up to believe in all
these fairytales it's the same thing God
is just a fairy tale what do you say to
that category here in philosophy and
category is conducted when people make
false analogies
so what emojis became things so thanks
and Santa Clause is very much a fairy
tale because Santa Clause can be
verified empirically when we mean by
this is that you can actually experience
the qualities that Santa Claus would
actually have to would have so for
instance you're talking about a big fat
guy regular super runny one reindeer
that's something that should be visual
to every human being on planets and wise
with God we're talking about attributes
that are outside of the physical realm
so when you make this comparisons like
all gods in the santa claus because they
don't have any empirical evidence
well first off santa claus is supposed
to have empirical evidence because santa
claus is something that should be able
to be empirically verified same thing
like fairies and the Loch Ness monster
and Bigfoot and things like this they
all have physical qualities but the
concept of God is beyond all physical
aspects so to compare them is unfair and
it's actually illogical
yeah makes sense good example tell us
now Olli you come back to religion and
now you're on a quest for true
Christianity you expound on that
that was the adventure I came back to
Christianity I sort of didn't go I
didn't really go near the Catholic
Church anymore because I had sort of a
bad experience with that and I thought
it was too ritualistic and repetitious
and in many ways so I wanted something
more intellectual so I I i became a
protestant christian i started following
philosophic they learned christians like
you know william lane craig and others
all them time to go
etc and i eventually during this time
and it's time to go to college because
of prior to that i didn't want to go to
college actually i was we have somewhat
of a similar background i think you're
more active in this realm now than
myself since my injury but i did do some
professional play for a few years and i
actually wanted to go further and make a
career out of it but i got hurt which is
one of the things that sort of prompted
me also to have these suicidal feelings
because my whole career path had
basically been destroyed so after of
course this traumatic experience
eventually decided to sit down and and
plan out my life and why I decide to go
to college finally so I started a little
late around 20 and I decided to
philosophy because my idle the time was
Bruce Lee and he did philosophy where
his major so I thought now why not I do
that too
so I got into philosophy and I started
to as for my undergraduate degree and I
started to study appreciated a very
intellectual level and as a result of
that I started to study about history
myself in moving from church to church
you know a lot of parents eventually
ended up in Orthodox Jewish thinking
them to be is as close to the truth as
possibly could be in a Christian
understanding you are really looking for
authenticity I mean you can see here
you're like going for you went into a
not do we get to non-dominate
denominational you that would be the
Protestant area okay so that's the
that's the Protestant area and now
you're looking for authenticity and you
said there were the closest to the true
Christianity Greek Orthodox
yeah historically speaking and even
their doctrines many of their doctrines
aside from the Trinity are actually very
close to Assam so for instance they
don't believe in original sin they don't
believe that Mary was the mother of God
for instance they don't they don't give
these titles they don't go down that
path they also don't have a pope that
they they had a much more inclusive
sense theological times more universal
theological sense then from the Catholic
tradition in a way then for me they were
more grounded in historical realities of
Christianity in the past but there was
still some problems like for instance I
mentioned the Trinity that still
bothered me significantly you mentioned
that that you felt that was like forced
on the force non-christian that this
what do you what do you mean by that
it's very forced because of nothing
within the descriptions or the
historical record indicated any sort of
mention of maturity it felt more like a
theory that was imposed upon the
tradition to explain a confusion but
certain strictures or certain things
that certain early first Robin you're
saying even many depressions in the past
eternity there was a little bigger than
Jura see anything like this
I'm sure they were guests in passing and
so it just did not sit well and there
was also a massive problem I could not
thank yourself and eventually help me
away from the champion together so what
advice do you have for people who are
also struggling with this I mean it's
it's in our nature to believe in God
when you say one God that makes sense
that you only worship this one creator
the one God and now the Trinity people
they get confused but then you know it's
something that's you know preached it's
taught and you feel like the odd one out
but you also people can relate to this
because you were a Christian you went
through this and you actually went deep
into the text looking for authenticity
so for someone who's struggling with the
same thing what advice do you give them
well first off I'd like to first sort of
help them to understand what that
confusion is my confusion was that
you're saying that there is one God who
is three persons in one substance now
first off this may make sense from a
very high philosophical position like
meaning if you've studied the books
in-depth you look into like neoplatonist
ik theology and things like this you can
somewhat understand what's going on and
why they would say these things but in
reality you know my first contention was
that it should not be this complex there
shouldn't be it shouldn't be this
convoluted that explaining oneness
should be this confusing or have to
require this much study to understand
and then the second problem was that
it's
though the whole person of Jesus ISA
early Salam did not fit well within this
construct than this three person Trinity
so how so
okay well in Christian tradition and all
Christians know this God is also
considered immutable meaning he cannot
change at all there's no change you
cannot change God God is the same from
Dave from the beginning to the end Alpha
Omega
the problem is when it comes into the
sacrifice if Jesus was really sacrificed
meaning that he actually died meaning
like dead like non-existent that means
within that three-day period before the
resurrection God was two not three yeah
for the sacrifice to have any reason
meaning those I mean you have you have
Christians like oh it's just symbolic
that of course then that just destroys
the whole theology to begin with yeah so
if he actually died that means that a
whole concert the whole understanding of
God has been unchanging perfect without
limitations completely collapses and I
had not found one theologian in the
Christian tradition or even
contemporarily that can solve this issue
in fact loses it usually they just sort
of ignore it and just say it's a mystery
yeah
so my advice would be that if it's
confusing you it's not you that's the
problem it's probably with analogy
because if one if the concept of one is
turning into quantum physics then
there's a problem yeah yeah that's deep
we're gonna leave you with that to to
mall over there think about that and
we'll right back with more insha'Allah
God willing with the rest of this
interview with our brother Ali
where it can't have defects in it can it
if it is literally God's Word yes
it cannot have defects I mean this was
written by men you know that this is a
collection right even if you have
Matthew Mark Luke and John the Gospel
according to according to right the
thing about the Quran and the biggest
and you know I'll leave you with this is
the biggest thing for me is if the Quran
is exactly what it says it is and this
doesn't matter whether you're Muslim or
not if the Quran is what it says it is
the Quran is literally the Word of God
delivered via Gabriel to Muhammad who
was an unlettered man who couldn't read
or write right and he was just told to
recite right that was the first thing
right first thing is don't recycle right
so if it is literally the Word of God
then that's pretty important to me and
before I became Muslim I said if this is
the Word of God then I'm gonna follow it
because I'd be stupid not to and thank
you guys that's all we have for today I
want you back here next week same time
subscribe right now so you can get the
show when it comes out delivered
directly to you I'm really enjoying
talking to Holly we kind of went over
the time so we have to cut this up into
two segments we're going to go ahead and
continue on we have a lot more to talk
about with far brother Ali so make sure
you come back next week
to enjoy the rest of his story thank you
Salaam alaikum Tala